welcome back to pennsylvania center when
dustin hoffman stayed up for three days
straight to appear tired for his role in
marathon man the great lawrence olivier
famously retorted my dear boy have you
tried acting i mean that is the job of
an actor right but some think that gay
roles for example should only be played
by gay actors and disabled roles by
disabled actors trans roles by trans
actors and presumably by that logic nazi
roles by nazi actors or is that
ridiculous is all of it ridiculous it's
a peculiar kind of method acting
zealotry and it's happening more and
more often it would consider for example
this sort of scene offensive
you know a woman said to me in the
casino today
she asked me if i was liberace's son
really mm-hmm
come here no no no no no no no
no you don't get anything oh yeah
that's matt damon and michael douglas uh
both obviously in liberation both acting
now my next guest is a gay man who says
his career suffered because hollywood
that great liberal bastion of tolerance
and fairness couldn't grasp or tolerate
or be fair about his ability to play it
straight he's of course direct to
producer movie superstar rupert everett
lovely to see you lovely to see you when
you watch as a gay man you watch that
scene from from candelabra the liberace
film to me is a straight guy it seemed
very sensitively done very realistic
and more than that for me watching that
film i was very moved by the amount of
work and detail that those two actors
bothered
to put into their research the way they
attacked the roles um i was i was i was
elated by it um
and there's there's many uh examples of
fantastic uh straight actors playing
great gay roles and then there's some
less good and um i think the question is
more why can't gay actors play straight
roles right that's the thing because
what happened to you was fascinating
because when you were deemed to be
straight you got all these romantic
leads in hollywood everyone loved you
and you were the hugh grant of your if
you don't mind the comparison i would
find that pretty repellent by the way no
i've said it it's out there uh you're
the hugh grant of your day and then you
came out and suddenly it was like right
no more work for you son we can't have
you as a straight romantic lead i don't
think it was actually quite like that to
be honest but um the thing that was very
frustrating when when i had my kind of
big hollywood moment which was
playing a gay best friend and being gay
uh i it was at that point very difficult
to graduate i knew i had to try and
graduate to playing something else apart
from just that role
and and it felt that it was more or less
impossible so my question is
i don't think uh gay actors should just
play the gay roles i think but the gay
actors should be able to play the
straight roles too i think some straight
guys play great gay roles it's not it's
not just about the gay roles and gay
actors and so on i want to show some
pictures here from other movies tom
hanks for example
in philadelphia actually is an example
of that but tom hanks in philadelphia to
me it was an incredibly powerful movie
which shot an unbelievably bright light
on the issue of aids and what tom hanks
did i thought he played the role
magnificently but more importantly he
brought tremendous numbers of eyeballs
to watch it because he's tom hanks and
it was a riskier period to do that as
well i mean when michael douglas and
matt damon did the candelabra movie
things have changed substantially yes
when he did that film uh it wasn't
really a subject that people would a gay
man who played that any more powerfully
and was there a gay actor out at the
time for example
who would have got the box office
success that tom hanks brought well and
therefore the light that was shot on the
issue this is the other question you
know people forget that hollywood is a
business uh so for example when scarlett
johansson uh
was uh stopped from playing uh a trans
role yeah uh
there wasn't there simply wasn't a
trance actress at that point big enough
to sustain a 50-60 million movie i found
that was a mistake of the trans
community because there were probably
lots of other trance roles in the film
that would have been played by uh trans
actresses and uh
scarlett johansson wasn't going to be
doing some portrait that was anti-trans
so i felt it was slightly
blinkered attitude eddie redmayne had a
similar thing with the danish girl you
know he got into trouble for that from
the trans community but your question
there is
he started the role as a boy so
who's going to play the boy
and the problem with that movie in the
end is it was just dull right which is
another a crime altogether but eddie
redmayne also played stephen hawking for
example and that was an amazingly
powerful fantastic role and again shot a
huge light on that
particular affliction with stephen
hawking had and i felt did it
brilliantly now i don't know why it
would need to be somebody who's got that
condition that stephen hawking had motor
neuron disease or a variant of it to be
as effective or more effective than
eddie redmayne well i don't think it
could have been because someone with
that condition just wouldn't be able to
uh do you know to be out there on the
set from six in the morning to late at
night i just played a role of someone
who'd had a very bad stroke uh it would
be impossible for someone who had had a
very bad stroke to really right start
working and that's the problem isn't it
once you once you take the last they
wanted to right but if you take the
logic to its logical end well you have
to be a murderer to play a mill this is
my point so here we go anthony hopkins
who played hitler right i mean are we
legitimately saying that if you're going
to play hitler now in a movie you have
to be a nazi similarly the sopranos the
sopranos
are we going to say now that they all
had to be the senior sopranos genuine
members of the mob right but on the
other on the other side piers you've got
to remember yes of course there
shouldn't be we shouldn't be making
rules about this yes of course it's
great uh for gay actors who've had quite
a hard time you know historically uh to
be playing more roles to be getting the
game it's quite frustrating uh i was
frustrated i remember going to see colin
firth in um
the film by tom ford and he made a major
screening i thought well thanks colin
that's the end of my career because you
know that role really should have been
mine yeah yeah yeah and then uh um and
uh so you know there's a frustration
about that of course uh and there's also
a point i do get which is what um some
disabled uh actors have made the point
to me that there's not the opportunity
at the grassroots level you know for
them to get on the right ladder to get
them into a position where they may get
these big roles because they're not
perceived to be big enough box office
stars they find that the system is a bit
oppressive to people uh and i get that i
get the fact that maybe disabled actors
do not get the same opportunities i get
that too but i mean the thing is what
how is the business meant to change for
that you know it's it's quite
complicated no i you know it's really
frustrating uh if you're a disabled
actor and uh it's um i but i don't think
the answer to richard iii
in stratford-on-avon for example which
greg
um the outgoing
head of the rsc said that it can only
now be played by disabled people i just
thought it was ridiculous to say that i
think it would be love i'd love to see
it played by a disabled actor by the way
but i don't see why
it's one of the great roles that actors
want to play you know acting is acting
movies and television and cinema
are a particular article that is not the
thing that ultimately
acting should mean what it says on the
tin it's acting that you as an actor one
of the best in the business you should
be able to play any role actually right
because i look at things like the period
drama bridgeton for example when you
look at bridgeton now it's actually a
fantasy in a way in the sense that has
many black actors playing
people that we know at the time were
almost uniquely white feudal people
right lords and so on i don't mind that
at all in the same way i wouldn't mind
if idris elba was the next james bond i
wouldn't mind if they suddenly made
james bond a woman in other words
there's going to be a kind of common
sense valve here you wouldn't mind or
you would mind i would mind if it was a
woman it's like women should get their
own spies right so you can't turn james
bond and i don't want him going
non-binary or any other things none of
that none of that um but i don't mind if
it's a black a black actor playing bond
at all that would i would think that's
fine same way bridgette and same way
doctor who is now a black gay actor
right and i think that's very exciting i
think that will give uh doctor who a
whole new impetus but that's a good
thing but that's a different thing i i
don't think anyone really if you
sometimes you're not a bigot we have a
problem with any of that let me just um
while i've got you i'm curious about
your view we've been talking a lot on
the show about cancer culture this sort
of rather insidious phenomenon which has
raised its ugly head you've always been
very outspoken you've always been pretty
uncensored in all the time i've known
you what do you feel about the society
that we now operate in these eggshells
everyone feels they have to tread on i
think it feels like uh the stasi to be
honest i think it feels incredibly
repressive i don't think it gets
it manages to achieve the aims
that uh that it's that it's after for
example
i don't know
uh
i've never met jk rowling for example
and i've never read her books and um
i have but i i'm willing to bet that
before this all happened she was not
someone who was anti-transsexual no
not remotely everything i didn't know
about it
nothing so but now she might be
she might easily be now well funny if i
interviewed i interviewed it was a big
scene up outside the emily and panker
statue in manchester where you have
women's rights uh campaigners we're
going to have a little rally there and
you have these trans activists turn up
and interview one of the trans activists
who just was incredibly abusive on the
show live calling me all sorts of names
and stuff and i don't have a transphobic
bone in my body i want trans people to
have equality and fairness but i also
want to safeguard women's rights i don't
think the two are incompatible no but i
think at a certain point now it's
reached a point where someone's got to
start trying to make peace
among these between these two groups and
i think the thing we tend to forget is
that in the kind of 24-hour history of
humanity these two million years the
women's movement only started literally
three seconds ago in that whole thing
yes so our brains are hardwired to
something
very anti-women too in a way so the
trance movement has come right on the
edge of the woman's movement in fact
that probably when you look at it from
further in advance the same thing we do
you're right though we need we need to
bring the extremities of these debates
because i don't believe people are trans
these people i i i it's dangerous to
call people uh turfs when they're not
because you make them into it jk rowling
to me is not transphobic she wants to
safeguard women's rights and she should
be applauded for doing so
we've run out of time great to talk to
you thank you very much tremendous
shaver mike so are you i'm really good
to see you later thank you thank you for
coming thank you very much good to see
you i want to play rupert everett in a
movie actually i want you to play me in
a movie i mean that would be good
actually i could you'd be good as me if
you just you know
i've lost some weight
glad to see you take care he's off it's
storming off oh am i meant to no not yet
it's fine i don't know if you want it
it's the done thing you can sit there
everybody
it wasn't exactly